hoy quiero contarles una historia
jose tiene 8 años
y tiene dos grandes pasiones en esta
vida
la primera su familia
y la segunda jugar fútbol
bueno no no no corrijo la primera es
jugar fútbol
y la segunda es jugar
y es que les cuento algo josé aprendió a
jugar fútbol pero que digo jugar amasar
el fútbol gracias al mejor maestro que
la vida le puso a su papá
se esperaba que diera el sábado para que
acompañara a su papá a verlo jugar el
dueño de la cancha viendo como la gente
lo respetaba su papá era siempre el
líder del equipo
eso lo aprendió josé del buen maestro
este sábado ya es tarde cercano a siete
de la noche
jose sabe que pronto tendrá que irse a
dormir porque cree que mañana se juega
la gran final del torneo de su escuela
bueno no todo ha sido tan bueno la
realidad es que el sábado pasado alguien
le metió un gol estuvo a nada de perder
la semifinal si es portero y miren que
ahora se ha prometido a sí mismo
que no va a caer un solo gol en su
portería su uniforme ya está sobre la
cama muy bien puesto doblado sus zapatos
ya están limpios de hecho los han
limpiado tres veces seguidas porque
siempre sale una nueva manchita
se va a acostar con la única encomienda
de saber que mañana será el día
definitivo de la gloria
la verdad es que se despierta aún sin
necesidad del despertador porque como
que había dormido muy poco jose
se viste realista y siente sus nervios
en el estómago que más de uno hemos
vivido casi cercano al examen a la
salida eso es lo que está viviendo josé
que se emocione contando los segundos
para saltar a la cancha tiene 8 años
pero él se siente todo un profesional
que más va a soñar
antes de salir de la recámara voltea
hacia la pared y le dice a memo ochoa sí
sí es un póster le dice va por ti
campeón
sale rápidamente justi baja las
escaleras pasábamos los vámonos que se
hace tarde de repente
vueltas a la esquina
está su papá y su mamá sentados
en silencio
serios
y su papá le dice muy pronto josemi y
joven por favor siéntate queremos hablar
contigo
pero todo está bien papá
mira hijo tu mami y yo estamos muy
preocupados
hemos visto que es más todo amistad esta
noche
el partido en las finales o hoy y yo te
enseñado que hay que hacer sacrificios
por el equipo de algunos papás al final
del partido anterior se acercaron con
nosotros y nos dijeron no vemos a jose
muy preparando
lo vemos nervioso
y es la final la que está en juego
así es que tu madre y yo bueno la verdad
es que yo yo le propuesto a tu mamá que
sea juan tu primo
quien tome tu lugar este fuego
yo sé sé perfectamente que juan no va en
tu escuela que juan tiene casi 12 años
pero hijo mira plan está más fuerte y él
va a poder bajar cualquier bola
no sé qué piensas pero
es la verdad josé no estaba pensando
nada
cámbiate no vayas ensuciando uniforme
jose pasó los 90 minutos quizás los
peores que su vida había enfrentado
sentado en la banca recriminándose
minuto a minuto como escena de película
que había hecho mal
porque sabía a todas luces que juan el
que estaba en la cancha
no pertenece a su escuela nunca había
entrenado con su equipo
no se merecía estar en ese juego
cuando enfrentamos todas las mañanas
emprendemos la tele escuchamos la radio
vemos noticias parece que vamos
coleccionando noticias de corrupción
claro yo sé que las noticias que vemos o
lo que sabemos generalmente desde
puestos públicos políticos fraudes
millonarios de grandes empresas
y no sé ustedes pero más de una vez me
he sentido bastante ajena a esos eventos
porque claro inmediatamente decimos
bueno pero mi familia no es así
yo no estoy ahí vemos los actos de
corrupción sumamente alejados a nuestra
vida cotidiana
lo que pasó esa mañana en la sala en la
casa de josé
fue un evento de corrupción
y no me refiero únicamente por la
pérdida del sueño de jose de no saltar a
la cancha
sino que a todas luces se pusieron de
acuerdo para llevar a alguien que ni
siquiera cumplía con la edad
reglamentaria y miren que a los
mexicanos esto que nos ha costado
bastante tenemos hasta el nombre para
eso no como le llamamos cachirules
efectivamente y díganme por qué no se
usa italia 90 no bueno entonces no es
novedad
la pregunta es
[Música]
los mexicanos hemos aprendido la
corrupción o como dijera por ahí alguien
celebra en nuestra patria somos
corruptos por cultura
nacimos o nos hicimos
esa es la gran pregunta porque fíjense
que jobs decía que el ser humano es malo
por naturaleza
desde aristóteles somos malos de mala
masa porque somos malos por naturaleza
decían ellos porque disfrutamos cuando
el de enfrente pierde o cuando nosotros
recibimos beneficio explicación nadie
tiene
gozamos de esa diferencia
acaso eso nos hace ser corruptos
no querer más no querer esforzarnos más
por obtener algo distinto
pero entonces de manera muy personal
siempre he creído algo que ortega y
gasset filósofo español ha dicho
soy yo y mis circunstancias
quiere decir que entonces hemos
aprendido este juego porque nos ha
convenido
la corrupción nos ha convenido y otra
vez no me refiero eventos grandotes de
estas noticias inmensas a la del día a
día a la del favor citó a la de no
conocer a alguien que me puede ayudar no
tendrás un contacto por ahí
a esa de todos los días
ras de cancha porque eso sí esa
corrupción no la queremos ver los
hacemos de ladito
es difícil cambiar fin fíjense que
méxico está en el lugar 138 de 180 de la
percepción internacional global de la
corrupción
hace 4 años éramos el lugar 95
considerando que 180 es el peor o sea
año contra año vamos para atrás
efectivamente pero este índice cuantos
dice el nivel que tenemos también nos
dice cómo nos reconocemos como corruptos
a nosotros mismos
la pregunta es podemos cambiar esto
podríamos cambiar nuestra realidad
porque yo les pediría que por un momento
soñábamos
con jugar en las grandes ligas
donde nuestra palabra contada
donde nuestra reputación estuviera
intachable donde ya no se dijera bueno
como es mexicano va a llegar tarde
es mexicano ten cuidado con la calidad
ya ves que luego no
nuestra reputación intachable soñemos un
momento con eso yo les puedo decir algo
hace 43 años en eeuu surge una ley por
sus siglas en inglés se llama lfp pero
tiene como espíritu principal esta ley
el diseño y de implementación de
programas de integridad
en las empresas
estos programas que ahora en mexico ya
existen son programas para establecer
lineamientos de control
y a la larga llevar a una productividad
y eficiencia a las empresas
que cree
a ser integridad y trabajar en la
integridad de jardinero
o si lo que pasa es que hemos pensado
siempre en corto plazo
cómo le hago para pasar esto
cuanto mejor por no pagar esta multa
resulta que en 2017 reporte el inegi las
empresas pagaron un millón 1.600
millones perdón de mordidas en un año
1600 millones de pesos pagados en
mordidas por parte de las empresas
cuánto cuesta la corrupción
1600 millones
no sólo eso
también cuesta la pérdida de sueños o
dígame de jose como cómo le fue a jose
jose perdió un sueño
no jugó esa final
qué deberíamos hacer los mexicanos para
cambiar entonces
porque hoy les tengo una noticia
si queremos cambiar y que lo hemos dicho
mucho debemos romper paradigmas
romper lo establecido de manera positiva
porque creen
depende de cada uno de ustedes depende
de nosotros
el contar con políticas de integridad
como compliance como una herramienta
global que ahora está en mexico
nos da muy bien ayuda
para establecer la integridad
y le explica la pequeña reflexión
volvemos a la sala de jose ese domingo
en la mañana
cuál de estos actores han sido ustedes
en su vida
está el papá de jose
quien armó toda la estrategia y propuso
que juan jugadas
esta jugada
calladito calladito entra en la cancha
está josé
con todo el dolor aceptó y se quedó en
la banca
pero está también la mamá
que vivió todo el sufrimiento del hijo
la emoción su uniforme los zapatos y vio
en su rostro esa carita diciendo ni modo
no voy a entrar a la final
tiene ellos así han sido ustedes
y les voy a contar por qué pregunto esto
porque el inegi también reporta el 2017
2 de 2016 reporta 2017 que únicamente el
4.6 por ciento de aquellos que viven un
acto de corrupción lo denuncian
el 96% de quienes sufren corrupción
no dicen nada
[Música]
quiere decir que el 96% de nosotros
somos la mamá de jose
a como nos escandalizamos vídeos
historias twitters historias de
instagram subimos lo que queremos y
leidy y lord
[Música]
pero cuando se trata de cambiar de
accionar ahí sí ya no
ay sí de ladito como que no veo como que
no siento
somos ese 96% saben que faltó en la sala
de jose esa mañana del domingo
al quinto jugador
a ese quinto jugador que se hubiese
levantado y dicho
esto no pasa
méxico y más que nunca necesita a ese
quinto jugador
a ese jugador que hace la diferencia
aunque toma responsabilidad de lo que le
toca
méxico nos necesita más que nunca
no sólo haciendo vídeos y quejas antes
eran cadenas ahora son
efectos virales no necesita actuando
donde nos toca lo que nos toca hacer
yo los invito a que nos llevemos tres
puntos nada más
el primero
es que nos hagamos responsables de lo
que nos toca porque les pediría también
algo
cerremos la historia de jose porque no
sabemos qué pasó con él en términos de
responsabilidad juan ya estaba en la
cancha
y qué creen nunca yo solo google
y las mamás del equipo contrario se
dieron cuenta inmediatamente que juan
era bastante alto que tenía casi 12 años
y fueron con el árbitro y le dijeron
haciendo ser responsables
--árbitro
él no es de este equipo
efectivamente secaron su credencial algo
mucha cita porque era la credencial de
jose
en ese momento descalificaron a su
equipo y no sólo eso el próximo año
tampoco van a jugar
debemos hacernos responsables no solo
del acto sino del efecto
segundo
debemos comprometernos nos cuesta tanto
comprometernos hemos generado una cadena
de disculpas permanentes porque no
llegue a tiempo o porque nos llegue de
plano o porque te entregue tarde algo o
porque no te pague cuando te dije que te
iba a pagar
es más estamos tan acostumbrados con la
falta de compromiso que hasta en una
boda invitamos a una hora sabiendo que
va a empezar en otra
es más aquel que llega temprano a la
fiesta se siente mal vayámonos más tarde
ya ves que todo empieza después
estamos acostumbrados a la falta de
compromiso y les diría algo hemos
racionalizado todos estos eventos es que
si le pagaran mejorar policía no pediría
dinero
es que si a mí me vienen los días de
vacaciones que yo me merezco no me
llevan a la papelera de la oficina
o no imprimir era tarea de mi bendición
en el momento de mi hora de trabajo
aunque no lo crean la hora en la que se
gasta más papel en una oficina después
de seis de la tarde cualquier vídeos que
eres más eficiente no hacen la tarea de
tus hijos
imprime lo que no quieres a gaspar en tu
casa
pero eso lo vemos bien lo hemos
racionalizado y decimos que bueno que lo
hago aquí aquí les sobra a mí me falta
que hubiera pasado
si ese domingo en la mañana
jose inmediatamente que se ha vestido se
ponen los zapatitos muy limpios
y antes de salir de la recámara voltee a
ver a memo ochoa y le dice
va por ti campeón sale jose
inmediatamente muy emocionado diciendo
papaya vámonos que se va a ser tarde
vámonos por favor
su papá serio y su mamá del silencio le
dicen por favor ven jose siéntate
mira hijo sabemos que estás nerviosa
sabemos que te meten en un gol el
partido pasado pero qué crees a pesar de
que varios papás nos han hecho de manera
en presión y en comentarios que juan tu
primo sea el que juegue tu madre y yo
queremos darte un mensaje hijo
estamos orgullosos de ti
sabemos lo que te ha costado cada minuto
en la cancha
si te meten un gol o no qué más nos da
estamos orgullosos de lo que has hecho
ándale campeón levántate que se va
acercando
soñemos con integridad muchachos
soñemos que esto sí se puede
el impacto lo estamos viviendo todos los
días nosotros
y conforme mahatma gandhi el cambio que
quieres ver en este mundo soñemos con
integridad muchas gracias